our next guest was an outstanding
linebacker at North Carolina State in
the 1970s not quite outstanding enough
to get drafted that didn't stop him from
having a four year NFL career with the
Eagles and Browns went on to be a Super
Bowl winning coach for the Steelers
widely considered one of the top three
coaches the Steelers have ever had over
the last 50 years on a personal note he
has three daughters who are way better
athletes than he ever was please welcome
Bill Cowher you look like you could
still play nice
do you miss yelling at somebody no no I
got it we got some guys you can yell at
mates and they're boomers in their fill
but I don't yell anymore do you miss it
um no you missed the emotional ups and
downs a little bit yeah you missed
Sunday's miss Sunday's yeah I mean I you
know I like most about coaching and was
probably strategizing I miss putting
together a game plan
I missed the the combative back and
forth strategic elements of the game on
Sunday you know the you know making the
adjustments and what you've prepared for
our week all sudden it's not fair which
I think Bill Belichick obviously is very
very good at and I think Shawn McBay is
good at the battle within the battle
it's you know because I think I always
say more games are lost in r1 and in
losing a game sometimes it's a case of
not acclimating to your opponent and
being able to flexible enough and you're
thinking and what you've put in to be
able to acclimate to a matchup that all
sudden wow I thought we could win this
we can't win this how do we protect them
or also I see something I can exploit
keep going after it because I register
I'd much rather have them do it on the
sidelines but if it works once I've run
it again what's the game you still look
back on and have a nightmare nightmare
probably the my third year the it was a
San Diego Chargers they
the Pittsburgh free AC championship game
and it was game we had beaten them
earlier in the season and actually beat
them and had rested some players so we
were very heavily favored in the game
and you know we started that game and it
was a game that number one it was in
Pittsburgh
and all that day was like 60 degrees
which is probably not a good omen in
itself right and but it came down to the
last play came down to the last play in
the end zone and Dennis Gipson knocked
away a pass from Neal done with the
Barry foster in the whole crowd just
went silent and I remember I always
remember that game because it was a game
that we were a defensive football team
and Barry foster at seventeen hundred
yards that year and you know we were
kind of we didn't impose ourselves on
people and forth and two and A two and I
went empty and throw the ball and I we
incomplete pass I go into the locker
room and I remember telling the players
at the time I said yeah there's no words
I can say they're gonna ease the pain
that you're feeling right now but this
understand that you know you've done a
lot for this city and this was not the
end it's just the beginning of us coming
back to being relative again and I went
back into the coaches and I told the
coaches when an amazing job they did
they made this team bearing that really
ever should be and they pushed all the
right buttons and I went in there saw
mr. Rooney and I said I'm sorry mr.
Murray for letting you down but he gave
me a little pat in his shoulder and I
saw my wife and she kept me a peck on
the cheek and I walked over and my
daughter was eight at the time Megan was
there and she looked amazing go dad I
said what she goes why don't you give
the ball to Barry Fawcett he could've
got two yards and Lauren says Lauren
says Megan mom said not to say it to dad
Nega said Lauren you said the same thing
in the box
girls girls girls girls girls hi I
probably should have gave the ball to
Barry Foster do you think Pete Carroll
faced that same kind of interrogation
with ya
I mean you know I think that the thing
that happens in these games is you do
reflect you reflect but you out think
yours like if that was a regular-season
game would you have made the same call
yes okay yes yeah you know you know I've
never second-guessed a call but you get
reflective as to why you did it and I
think if
you prepare the biggest thing is again
is just move on from it
you mean you make a decision and I've
said that the players before after
season you listen you know it I want you
here we probably can't keep you if they
give you what you want you're gonna have
to make a monetary decision what the
value is to being a part of something
special um but you know if you decide to
go don't look back don't look back you
know I mean because I think if you put
thought into something you put
preparation to something whatever
happens it was meant to happen and so I
just you reflect on it so you learn from
it by only ever second-guess it talking
to Bill Keller now working with CBS they
will host the Super Bowl and Bill is
receiving the Pat Summerall award at the
legends for charity awards dinner that
benefits the st. Jude's Children's
Research Hospital that'll be Thursday
night and that benefits st. Jude's you
can see him on CBS NFL today and he's
Super Bowl today that'll be on Sunday
clear up a story for me you went to NC
State Rivers went to NC State
alright draft on yep I was told you
loved Phillip Rivers you wanted Phillip
Rivers over Ben Roethlisberger were you
overruled no I mean we knew we saw the
three quarterbacks for you we talked all
three I'm at the combine it was Eli
Manning Phillip Rivers and Ben
Roethlisberger we were picking 12th we
had Tommy Maddox at the time I think
everyone is under the consensus that
pretty much was that Eli and Phillip
we're gonna go very high we were not
gonna trade up to get either one of them
we felt like we really needed an
offensive line and matter of fact we're
thinking about taking Stacey Andrews and
it was an Arkansas guard at the time and
so we came in we've talked to Ben and I
remember telling Kevin I said you think
there's any chance he could slip to us
and he said yeah he goes I think there
is and I said well let me go back and
look at him and so we went back and we
looked at him and I think when you
watched Ben play there's no question his
athletic ability was above everybody
else the only questions you had was he
played at Miami of Ohio you know the
quality of opponent and then you looked
at Eli you look at Phillip you know
they's these guys play Division one they
could come in tomorrow and be the face
of your organization where you thought
well but then you know all sudden he got
there I said well with tommy maddox we
can sit him for
we're as one behind tommy maddox at
least a year and it would be a perfect
scenario so no I mean III I think I
don't think he even came down to rating
the three of them i the question was
they're all three gonna be good
quarterbacks would Ben get to us and I
think that was the biggest question that
we had at the time was would Ben
Roethlisberger be there with our 12th
pick and when he was it really wasn't no
brainer and then I thought okay sit for
a year with end ups pardon week and week
three I also was thinking about you when
I knew that you were gonna be our first
guest if a play if you were involved in
a play that the Saints were involved in
and you saw what was happening on the
sidelines and you're Sean Payton I have
to believe you would have been more
animated like I didn't know if Sean was
animated enough as strange as that's
gonna sound to be that upset with what
was obviously helmet-to-helmet pass
interference does that matter to an
official like when you sell it do you do
you perform to let them know you just
made a horrible call I think exactly I
would say those exact words and I'd go
back and say come on guys let's respond
I think the biggest thing you can do the
worst thing you can do is dwell in them
in a moment I think as a coach yes it's
very upsetting
I affected them in in overtime I thought
that they let it carry over exactly and
I think it's most important thing I go
back to a playoff game that we had
against the Indianapolis Colts and they
made a call against Troy Polamalu they
overturned an interception and I knew
was they were going through this whole
thing that you know this is not gonna
turn out well but you cannot dwell on a
call and I think as a coach you gotta
get the players back on the on the task
at hand
you know when they left that field for
Sean Payton and his badge that call was
they still 223 they had a three-point
lead come on we just got to stop him you
know and I think so I think for Sean
McGee he's pushed all the right buttons
when you think about the fake punt that
he called early in that game that turned
around that entire game
fourth and one we all say go for the
touchdown which I thought kicked a field
goal and all of a sudden then take a
57-yard field goal if he doesn't make
that field goal if you don't if you put
the both you know make the 15 go there
one field go away from kicking going
down loosen the game so I think he's
made all the right decisions and they've
worked out every one of them for him and
I think in this game itself two is going
to be a case of making sure that you
make the right decisions
aggressive to stay aggressive in your
thinking because you know bill oh but
also when you look at a call like that
would it help you if you're Sean Payton
if the league comes out publicly and
says we missed like the longer this goes
I don't like why not just come out and
say we made a mistake because it feels
like we want to pin you down and say all
right commissioner did you get that you
know why not come out and say you made a
mistake is that gonna make anything
better if you're new orleans i don't
think so
i mean i think we all saw it also was a
missed call but why wouldn't they come
out and say something well I don't know
and I've never you know I've never
counted on you know I mean what's it
gonna what's it gonna make you feel
better you know makes you feel better if
they admitted they were wrong I mean
listen we lost the game okay we had a
chance to win the game even though with
a bad call there's going to be bad calls
in a game there's 100 3540 plays it's
not and I think Sean McVeigh said it and
I've set up a force an imperfect game
and it's gonna be it's gonna be elements
to take place because it is bangbang and
I don't want review for everything I
really don't you know I'd like to you
know that's a call that was missed but
respond to it don't overreact to it
respond to it respond as a team if
something happens you know when you make
a bad throw you make a better reception
we're gonna sit there and just say or
you just let's say sorry the whole team
no let's go it just respond to it you
miss a tackle I'm sorry no I don't hear
it sorry just respond to it I think if
you're a football team and you respond
to those situations that is the quality
of a champion to me because there's
going to be a band flow in every game my
opinion feel like you're yelling at me
[Laughter]
what if Wade Phillips the defensive
coordinator the Rams called you and said
bill can I I'd like to pick your brain
here what would you do against Brady
well what did you tell Wade Phillips and
I've gone against bill multiple times is
just expect the unexpected but is it
bill you're going against oh you're
going against Brady it's bill I mean
it's it's it's you know it's it's the
Josh McDaniel me that's how you're going
against and Bill's a part of that and
what those guys do they do a great job
of putting in a plan each week it's
gonna be probably a little bit different
but if you don't stop it last week a
Kansas City Chiefs I'm Olson you're not
gonna you're gonna this let me run the
football
yeah if you don't stop it he'll just
keep doing it and all of a sudden you
want to open up James White's gonna be
in the game Tony Michelle with all yeah
dinners Rex Burkhead it comes in in the
fourth quarter you know Lee so Julian
Edelman you better take him away James
White you better take him away Tom Brady
make him feel uncomfortable somehow some
way because you know where he's gonna be
he's gonna be in that pocket so you know
he's gonna be in that pocket and so you
got to make him uncomfortable to some
degree not all the time but I tell you
one you better stop the run and the
other thing that comes with the run is
the play-action there'll be a some
play-action pass off of it so you know
what you know don't get it's okay for me
to gift for that's a lot to stop here no
no no it's not so I'm just saying I am
flexible enough one thing I have right
now is I know I'm gonna have a run I'm
gonna have a run blitz if I'm wait I had
a run blitz
I'm gonna bring some safeties up there
mark Baron has played very well and
they've played the run very very well
Eason Adamic ensue
Aaron Donald these two guys inside have
played as well as anybody in the
postseason
Aaron Donald is attack he's a disruptive
football player so I missed off the run
the other thing I want to do is I got to
take away Edelman and I thought that
they did a very good job last week
taking away Michael Thomas if you watch
it they took a scene you're not gonna be
as well Michael Thomas so the heat
they're gonna do that a keep to leave
getting him back is huge and I think
he's gonna take them their way and they
gotta continue to play the run the way
they played to run last week against the
Saints do you run at great players yeah
you do so I'm gonna run right at Donald
in Sioux I'm going on I want to know
where you are
exactly well you can't run out on both I
would run it Aaron Donald I would make
sure I have two guys that are very much
in sync because he will split a double
team and don't try to get him from a
backfield he's too athletic and so I
think he's a very disruptive guy so I
cannot let him get into the backfield
and be disruptive he's also can be
disruptive in a passing game so you know
that's one thing that Aaron Tom Brady
will be aware of where is Aaron okay if
I had an open draft no quarterbacks you
got first pick right now yeah Aaron
Donald okay I think I think he's the
most disruptive player defensive player
there is
and I say that for this reason because I
think of the game has become a very
quick throwing game we used to talk
about edge rushers before yeah but I
think the inside rusher it's a quicker
spot to a quarterback and this guy is
the most disruptive guy in football
well the edge rusher it is strange as
it's gonna sound can't get there quick
enough right whereas if you have
somebody who can go because I think if
you beat the Patriots I gotta have
strong guys up the middle right Ravens
did this the Giants when they beat
Belichick and Brady I got to have that I
got to start there and if I start there
I feel pretty good because it's gonna
make my secondary look a whole lot
better right what do you think oh
absolutely
I mean I think Aaron Donnell coming up
and try to get him into a one-on-one
matchup you know we go back to what they
used to do with Reggie White you put
five guys across the board and you put
Reggie White right on the center what's
the quickest distance between two points
is a straight line
well Mean Joe green too used to line up
right off the center to Alan page those
guys are the most disruptive people in
that you know he's a three down player
and I think to me that's the guy
final question for coach Cowher last
time you were in a fight last time I was
in a fight yeah I was playing I was a
player I fought all the time and I
played well why are you so angry because
that's that's how I played did you I
played angry I did I played um I was a
different player when I stepped on the
field I had to I wasn't very big and I
wasn't very fast but I was gonna out
will you
and so I had to get mad at you I make it
personal I made it personal
did you have an off the field fight um
in college how'd it work out I always
walked away okay
would your chin be an advantage or
disadvantage if you if you were a boxer
you're like you give me a big target
there
Yeah right I don't know is it good or
bad Oh probably not a good thing no calm
but you know it wasn't always this big
oh can you take a punch oh yeah okay
Paulie come over here
dan there's some people you look at and
you looked at like if you punch them he
would like laugh and smile and then
punch you back that's what mr. Carr
looks like yeah you could be a villain
yeah I think so he thinks in a movie
yeah I think like a Bond villain like
your smiles too good though yeah we'd
have to well it's kind of there's a Dale
Earnhardt senior look a to you as well
when you smile I could see that yeah
yeah everything isn't always as you
perceive it I didn't like that coach
congratulations on the Pat Summerall war
thank you and four more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show act
[Music]